violence commise dans un cabinet médical
à Paris de secrétaire médicale agressif
altercation filmée par un tiers avec son
portable dépôt d'une main courante d'une
main courante par les victimes
ça on l'a su dernièrement chez le mari
on l'a su dernièrement mais il me semble
que s'il y a eu un dépôt de main
courante et que
le ministère de la Justice
qui avait dit qu'elle était totalement
inconnue si ce n'est pour une affaire de
de violence conjugale en 2018 là on est
sur une affaire de 2019 et je pense
qu'elle n'a pas abouti judiciairement
cette affaire ce qui fait qu'elle n'est
pas dans le dossier de la justice alors
trouvez ça en fait
ça c'est les fichiers police d'accord et
les fichiers police sont séparés des
fichiers justice la justice c'est
Cassiopée c'est un fichier des des
condamnations et au niveau de la police
là il doit y avoir toujours une enquête
préliminaire sur cette affaire elle a
pas abouti visiblement pour des raisons
que j'ignore elle doit être encore en
cours
si tenter quelqu'un travaille dessus non
alors
Damien est actuellement à la prison de
Fresnes selon des révélations de BFM TV
elle y ferait preuve d'une d'un
comportement très étrange elle a l'air
totalement détachée et passionnée par sa
propre histoire comme fasciné par son
crime elle regarde toutes les émissions
et de nous regarder d'ailleurs au moment
où on se parle
elle sort peu mais ça c'est le règlement
et je crois qu'elle a une heure de
promenade par jour puisqu'elle est
placée à l'isolement il reste du temps
elle regarde la télé
enquêteurs actuellement
et donc il y a un certain nombre de
choses qui sont lancées les enquêteurs
vont travailler comme on dit en Belgique
ils vont faire des devoirs pour les
juges c'est les commissionsatoires le
juge va demander aux enquêteurs de
probablement d'aller en Algérie
d'entendre de la famille qu'elle a
là-bas
tous ses amis tout son entourage on va
reconstituer
par heure par heure mais séquence par
séquence toute la vie de cette femme
s'appelle le curriculum vitae et pour
savoir
on trouvera sans doute encore des des
choses
incroyables
oui le but maintenant des enquêteurs
c'est de reconstituer son portrait et
c'est vrai que les antécédents prouvent
quand même une personnalité violente
donc ça va agir défavorablement parce
que il y a eu des menaces il y a eu des
coups portés donc même s'il y a pas eu
de suite judiciaires pour elle là ça
devient entre guillemets de plus en plus
difficile de plaider le coup de folie
parce que c'est une répétition d'acte de
violence donc c'est très négatif et très
lourd pour elle c'est fait alors comme
vous l'avez dit parce qu'en effet le
plus clair de son temps devant la
télévision et plus chez les reportages
et interventions d'experts sur le
meurtre dont elle est accusé
donc quand vous avez dit elle sort très
peu regarde beaucoup les journaux
télévisés des crises de confrères elle
semble fascinée par sa propre affaire ça
arrive souvent ça
on a rarement des retours sur le
comportement des accusés ou des suspects
quand ils sont incarcérés sauf quand
c'est Francis saulmes quand c'est
fournirait ou des gens comme ça
maintenant je pense que fournirait avec
une forme de fascination pour pour ses
affaires enfin en tout cas c'était il
avait un ego surdimensionné et il était
il répondait à certains journalistes il
écrivait il faisait des courriers et
Valérie les enquêteurs aussi travaillent
sur une fascination qu'elle aurait pour
le chiffre 10 mais c'est qu'on a
retrouvé le chiffre 1 et le chiffre 0
sur le corps de la petite et en fait et
ils sont en train de travailler tout
autour de ce chiffre et notamment ils
ont noté une coïncidence qui n'en est
peut-être pas une parce que toutes les
vidéos qu'elle poste notamment sur Tik
Tok elle le poste le 10 de chaque mois
donc ils sont en train d'essayer de
remonter pour voir si il y aurait pas là
quelque chose à creuser à travailler
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
autour de du 10 c'est vrai que voilà on
entendu plein de choses de fascination
alors on parlait de rites et notamment
George Fennec parler d'un rite satanique
alors peut-être que il y aurait des
liens et des ficelles à tirer
en 2010 aussi parce que les enquêteurs
donc il y avait énormément de choses
autour du chiffre 10 mais dans ce cas-là
ça voudrait dire que c'était prémédité
la justice n'appartenait après
méditation pour l'instant et de toute
façon c'est compliqué de remonter on
peut descendre mais difficilement monter
mais rien ne rien ne dit qui après midi
si on se voit le chiffre 10 qui est là
ce qu'elle a fait en termes d'actes
criminel
c'est une chose
kidnappée attraper cette petite Lola
c'était a priori pas prémédité en tout
cas les magistrats n'ont pas considéré
que ça l'était à l'isolement là
actuellement elle est à l'isolement
aucun autre détenu elle ne peut pas en
être autrement et puis au-delà de ça son
esp de survie si elle est mélangée avec
les autres détenus c'est moins de 10
minutes
elle se fait elle se fait casser la
figure elle se fait tuer c'est et même
parmi les surveillantes on les a trié
sur le volet ah oui oui oui
qui se lâcherait
là à la prison de Fresnes c'est voilà
toutes les toutes les femmes qui sont
incarcérées là-bas elles se disent
si elle sort c'est c'est
en cours de promenade avec les autres
elle rentre pas vivante elle a aucune
chance je pense qu'elle ramasse
absolument toutes les toutes les codes
détenus sur elle
elle a fait des choses épouvantables et
même les
les surveillantes ont été triés sur le
web
qui disait moi je vais si je peux pas
j'ai pas envie de la suivre je peux pas
surveiller c'est de la responsabilité du
directeur qui qui sait qu'il y a des
sans doute des surveillants qui sont
peut-être un petit peu brutales donc il
a vraiment ils ont choisi des
surveillantes plus
urbaines c'est fou
pénitentiaire pour la l'isoler à double
tissu c'est-à-dire l'isoler des autres
et la protéger d'elle-même en raison de
possible présentation suicidaire etc
donc c'est vraiment une détenus
aujourd'hui c'est la détenue en France
la plus surveillée aujourd'hui